I'm sorry wait who are you captain america
i thought captain america was on the moon
Welcome back everyone on your left marvel is
making captain america four you probably saw
the announcement the past couple of days so we'll
break everything down it's going to be all about
falcon's new version of captain america so
obviously it's going to be a little bit different
from the comics i'll explain what's going on and
what they've said about it so far if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we have marvel loki episodes coming up
real soon i'll be doing videos for all the marvel
disney plus stuff this year and just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened during
falcon and winter soldier if you have not seen
those episodes yet or you haven't seen the finale
yet but the big news you probably just heard is
that malcolm spellman the showrunner from falcon
and winter soldier is being hired by marvel or was
hired by marvel to write the captain america for
script so they haven't announced what the official
title is you can post all your predictions in the
comments below i'll talk about all my predictions
for the movie just based on what they've said
so far and the stuff that they teased during the
falcon winter soldier finale because kevin feige
the producers were saying they were using falcon
and winter soldier to set up some very specific
movie stuff that was happening now we know that
they were talking about captain america four so
when you wonder what they're setting up with big
plot twists like sharon carter power broker
and the other stuff that's happening with say
like the thunderbolts us agent in val julia
louis-dreyfus character all captain america
4 stuff in addition to a couple other projects
as well probably but just in terms of the actual
title or what they might call captain america
4 you have to think they're escalating things
even bigger than captain america civil war so just
keep that in mind when you're thinking of theories
but they did have that very specific title card
at the end of falcon and winter soldier it was
sort of like their mid-credit scene where they
have the brand new captain america and the winter
soldier i know a lot of people are like why are
they still calling bucky the winter soldier if
they're calling falcon captain america now because
this whole arc during the series was crossing all
the names out of that list captain america's
book that he was using to also atone for all of
his misdeeds and killings that he performed as the
winter soldier a lot of people were sending me fan
art of titles that just said captain america and
the white wolf which does sound kind of cool but i
think the whole idea with his white wolf identity
is that it's just a wakanda thing just the black
panther characters it's like his special name in
wakanda so only those characters will probably
call him that unless sam just wants to tease
him a little bit more in the future when they're
doing their whole buddy cop thing i do think
they're gonna finally pay off sam captain america
finally referring to him as buck because remember
earlier in the episodes he was saying only steve
gets to call me that because he knew me longer
but i think everyone kind of likes the idea of
them joking on each other just a little bit so
i think they'll continue to do that even though
they do feel genuinely closer to each other but i
think one of the safer predictions to make is that
most of the main characters who survive the falcon
and winter soldier finale will come back in some
form in captain america for speaking of characters
coming back i know a lot of people were wondering
whether or not we'd see an old man captain america
steve rogers cameo scene during falcon and winter
soldier well the series blew through the plot so
quickly that it does make sense why he did not
show up but they kept referencing him in that
moon base all the time even at the beginning
of the episode there was that agent that asked sam
who are you and he says i'm captain america before
going about his business and then as he walks
away says i thought the captain america was on
the moon a lot of people have been wondering if
that's actually meant to be an easter egg for the
avengers video game i think it's actually closer
to being a reference to the nick fury base that
he had on the moon in the comics also in the mcu
he has the space station with the scrolls which
is the next best thing to a moon base it doesn't
seem like a moon base because we haven't really
seen the exterior of it it just seems like a space
station all the big news trades were reporting
earlier this year that chris evans was preparing
to sign a deal that would have him come back as
captain america or come back as steve rogers a lot
of people wondered what that meant maybe it could
mean him coming back for a cameo as old man steve
rogers well the really interesting clue about what
happened to him after the end of avengers end game
is that if you look at the captain america exhibit
as they're walking through there's a big section
that just details the plot of avengers end game
if you read that through it actually says the
captain america retired after that adventure so
i think they're trying to imply that he secretly
retired to nick fury's space station there was
a whole big thing with chris evans trying to deny
it personally i do not believe marvel actors when
they say that they're doing or not doing things
just because there is a long history of marvel
actors denying that they're in projects when
clearly they are but if they were ever going to
bring him back for a cameo scene captain america
4 would be the place to do it but the people who
were posting about this chris evans project him
coming back for new marvel projects said that it
was not captain america four it was for other
projects so it's just open to theory crafting
what that could possibly be also if we're talking
about old man captain america cameo scenes at the
end of falcon and winter soldier there was a very
big isaiah bradley seen paying off his storyline
honoring him in the captain america exhibit at
the smithsonian so i'm really hoping that they
also bring back isaiah bradley during captain
america 4 and maybe even give us a flashback
scene even if it's a short flashback scene of when
he was fighting winter soldier in the korean war
just some kind of flashback scene to him being
super badass next big thing is all the thunderbolt
stuff and dark avengers that they're slowly
setting up through the val character and obviously
thunderbolt ross in the background through falcon
and winter soldier so obviously we didn't get a
really big thunderbolt ross cameo scene not a huge
surprise because there weren't a ton of big movie
actors there were some but they used the val
character as sort of their dark version of nick
fury slowly putting together what sounds like the
thunderbolts in the background through u.s agent
like she said in that post-credits scene a lot of
weird stuff is going to be happening that's just
sort of a general blanket statement about the
craziness that's going to be happening during
marvel phase 4 and the movies in the disney plus
series when she says they won't be needing people
like captain america it means they're going to
be doing black ops really shady stuff and that
is standard fare for thunderbolts characters
they also sort of tie this scene to the baron
zemo scene of him on the raft and she was
kind of joking like they were friends our
friend zemo got the last laugh baron zemo was the
original person to put the thunderbolts together
in the comics so it makes sense that he would be
associated with potential future thunderbolts plot
normally have would have said that they would
have handled thunderbolt stuff more legitimately
during falcon and winter soldier season 2
but now because we have captain america 4
coming up before that it seems much more likely we
see that stuff start to form in the background of
what's happening during captain america 4. so even
if they don't legit introduce the thunderbolts or
the dark avengers say which i'll talk about in
a second during captain america for maybe some
easter eggs or a post credit scene for them but it
does sound like the val the madame hydra character
julie louis dreyfus does have a big future in
marvel phase four hopefully she sticks around for
a long time i felt like she worked fantastic with
the small scenes that they gave her during falcon
and winter soldier you just have to picture her
talking circles around all the other big avengers
level characters clearly they want you to feel
like she wields incredible power when they call
her a dark version of nick fury but for those of
you asking about hydra i don't think that she's
associated with any kind of new version of hydra
or anything like that the whole thing with the
falcon version of captain america when sam became
captain america in the comics it was the all-new
all different period they kind of did a greatest
hits rerun of all the original steve rogers
captain america stories from when he first debuted
in the comics so he faced modern incarnations of a
lot of the original captain america villains like
they started off with the hydra story arc there's
an issue with him punching red skull the same way
that steve rogers was punching hitler on the cover
of captain america number one so that's what i
mean when they said they were doing a re-run of
original steve rogers greatest hits there were
a lot of you that were trying to make serpent
society predictions for captain america for
they even did a falcon captain america version
of that story arc in his comics but then they
took things in a really twisty direction they
did the whole hydra cap twist and i don't think
they're gonna do anything like that in the mcu
like they're not gonna bring chris evans back to
do a version of hydra cap that was an incredibly
unpopular character what they did do though was
they introduced the torres character as the next
version of the falcon so he took the mantle from
falcon when falcon became the next captain america
in the actor who plays torres on falcon and winter
soldier of the series said that he was totally
ready to become the next falcon but they haven't
told him anything about actually doing that
but that's kind of what they're laying the seeds
for when he gave him his wings like just keep him
do whatever you want repair him during that ending
scene where he was watching his speech on his
laptop you can kind of see him with his tool bench
there with all the tools laid out getting ready to
fix the wings then there's all the us agent john
walker stuff i do think that they'll bring him
back at some point during captain america four i
don't know how big of a character he's going to be
in white russell the actor who plays the character
he's actually kurt russell's son in real life
ego the living planet in the mcu so it's a nice
marvel reference even though there's no real
connection between us agent and ego the living
planet but they turned him into the full-blown
u.s asian character from the comics with a
black accurate costume i'm sure eventually when
he shows up again they'll give him the us agent
version of the captain america shield it just has
us in the center instead of the captain america
star and it's painted to look the similar color
scheme as his costume but he's more of an
anti-hero and he is on the government payroll
per what val is saying here like that was the
whole idea with him redeeming himself during
the finale so he's a little more balanced now
mentally a little more emotionally stable but he's
a character who will be doing really shady black
ops for val who would also work really well inside
a thunderbolt scenario too so he could also show
up during a future thunderbolt series as well the
other big thing you have to consider is because
captain america 4 is the fourth movie in the
franchise they're also doing thor 4 so it's not
the first time that they've done a fourth movie
in a single character's solo film but the way
they've been talking about thor 4 makes you think
about the way they're trying to set up captain
america for because the whole idea with thor 4
love and thunder is that it's supposed to be even
bigger and escalate things even more than what was
happening during thor ragnarok the way they talk
about thor 4 all the actors say that it's kind of
like avengers 4.5 sort of like a captain america
civil war situation where a lot of what happens
sort of shakes the foundation of the mcu on a
fundamental level so they'll have to do something
similar during captain america four to escalate
that over how big captain america civil war was
well how do you do that there's only a couple big
story lines that would fit with what they're doing
right now and what they've set up during falcon
and winter soldier and a lot of that gets into
the whole idea of the dark avengers thunderbolt
ross red hulk and the thunderbolts still a bit
of a blank canvas in terms of villains they'll
probably start introducing some new villains
from the comics instead of going back to old
ones but i think the whole idea is eventually
the next form of civil war that you'll see will be
thunderbolt ross himself becoming red hulk and him
becoming something of an antagonist in the mcu but
taking it in more of a u.s agent type of direction
so really good example during the falcon and
winter soldier series the way they pitched the
us agent character at the beginning john walker
before he became u.s agent is that he's this new
version of captain america is very optimistic
but kind of turns into an antagonist even though
technically he's not a villain i think it's more
likely that that's the way they would play their
big red hulk thunderbolt ross twist in the future
of the mcu the whole thing with a sharon carter a
power broker twist i know a lot of people want to
believe that she might be a scroll it's totally
possible but i just think that they want to pitch
her as a darker version of the character now
who sort of plays with both the heroes and the
villains on both sides it just makes her a much
more complex character really good example is we
have the iron man armor wars series on disney plus
that's happening next year war machine will be
the main character during that we saw him cameo at
the beginning of falcon and winter soldier because
sharon carter trades in a lot of black market tech
and stolen goods she could also be part of the
path to other villains in the mcu getting their
hands on iron man's technology which is basically
what armor wars is you remember iron man 2 where
you have justin hammer trying to basically do
knock off clones of iron man's armor and it
just winds up going haywire imagine the worst
possible version of that happening in the mcu
they also kind of imply that the val character
has her hands and a lot of really shady stuff
so it would make sense that she would eventually
have a connection with sharon carter if she needs
to supply any potential u.s asian or thunderbolts
missions sharon carter would be the place to get
those weapons from what would be the next major
conflict that's happening through marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5 to divide the characters in a
really fundamental way well you have things like
mutant rights because they're slowly introducing
the x-men characters from the fox movies
the whole idea is that by the time we get to 2022
2023 we'll slowly start seeing more of the x-men
characters start popping up more mutant characters
they kind of tease that during Wandavision a
little bit with her children because in order
to be considered a mutant you have to be born
with your powers that's basically the qualifier
bringing back around to the whole weapons plus
super soldier storyline during falcon and winter
soldier i'm hoping that they also bring weapons
plus back around when thunderbolt ross comes
back for potential cameo in captain america for
to sort of set up weapon x down the road it's
all about the idea that each iteration of the
weapons plus program tries different methods
to create super soldiers so when they got to
wolverine weapon 10 they were experimenting
on mutants and they were using the adamantium
i would completely lose it though if he does show
up in a cameo scene during captain america four
the way that spider-man just surprised showed
up during captain america civil war like yeah
we got spider-man in the mcu now but aside from
any x-men characters showing up in a big way i
think the biggest thing they've teased so far in
the background that they could legitimately use to
escalate over captain america civil war would be
the concept of the dark avengers but everyone post
all your predictions for captain america 4 in the
comments below remember it's going to be about two
three years before we see that movie so i will do
more videos about it when we get more information
while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my falcon winter soldier finale post
credit scene video and click here for my
full falcon winter soldier episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!